der anlass für die durchsuchung ist dass
wir hinweise bekommen haben dass die
menschen die wir gestern aufgesucht
haben
kinderpornografische so jugend
pornografisches material heruntergeladen
hatten besessen haben und auch selber
getauscht haben
insgesamt haben wir gestern bei 50
menschen durchsuchungen durchgeführt und
konnten sie dabei bereits neue
erkenntnisse bekommen beziehungsweise
was haben sie bei den durchsuchungen
gefunden
wir haben eine vielzahl von asservaten
sicherstellen über 2000 also warte
bundesweit die jetzt nach einer
intensiven auswertung bedürfen ein
großteil der als erwartet sind
elektronische datenträger nach einer
ersten sichtung haben wir auch schon
viele datenträger gesehen die unseren
anfangsverdacht erhärtet haben und wir
sicher sind dass wir bei den richtigen
war die datenmengen wachsen also immer
weiter in diesem fall bergisch gladbach
und genauso auch die zahl der
tatverdächtigen wie viele sind jetzt
geht es bei ihnen in der soko als
tatverdächtige gelistet aus dem gesamten
verfahren der berenberg was die kölner
polizei das land nrw einsatz führend
begleitet haben wir über 200
tatverdächtige jetzt deutschland war die
identifizierung
die mehrzahl außerhalb nrws